you don't have to have a Russian
champion to win a suitable but him it
was the first one to do it and that's
one of the dilemmas at running back is
that the league knows that even win
Super Bowls and not have the Emmitt
Smith back there or not have Zeke back
there consequently when we are looking
and putting Zeke's contract in place
we've got to realize that the ultimate
goal is to win the Super Bowl Jerry
Jones with CBS DFW that's a far cry from
Ezekiel Elliott is the straw that stirs
our drink and I think the indication is
now coming from the Cowboys with Ezekiel
Elliott dug in they are digging in as
well they are not going to cave they are
not going to capitulate they're not
going to become desperate because for
the Cowboys they will be doing this over
and over and over again negotiating with
players and if you start giving in when
do you stop giving in so even though
there's a sense
Cowboys very much would like to get to a
Super Bowl and win it every team would
love to do it Jerry Jones seems to have
a higher sense of urgency than other
owners because he's very aware that
there's only so many chances he has left
while he's the owner of the team to win
that fourth Super Bowl trophy on his
watch it looks like for now they're
trying to create the impression Chris
that they're not going to be an easy
mark here and they're not just gonna
give a Zico I'll at what he wants we'll
see yeah if they can execute it but at
least for now they're trying to set it
up that well yeah I mean you know what
is caving in right I mean you know what
what what is our definition of it right
now I mean are we saying they're not
gonna cave in and they're not gonna give
them anything I mean I think it
ultimately this team is in their Super
Bowl window right now when they're going
to cave into Ezekiel Elliott maybe
they're not gonna cave to certain
numbers and that's the one thing we
don't know about this situation yet I
mean I think we all expect that the
numbers are gonna be bigger than Todd
Girly's contract and they deserve to be
from what Ezekiel Elliott has done he's
the next guy up he's led the NFL in
rushing to it in the last three years he
been the focal point of that offense oh
yeah and he led the team in receptions
last year so I think ultimately like I
said the Cowboys with being in the Super
Bowl window as talented as their team
are they're gonna have to give a Zeki
ollie at a new contract it's just how
much money how much guaranteed money is
gonna be you know worth when when all
said and done and I think they prefer to
have the flexibility of a guy who is
basically pay-as-you-go they're entering
year four of that rookie contract it's
about 3 million in change for Elliot
this year he gets the 5th year option
salary next year which is north of 9
million and then they could go franchise
tag for one year franchise tag for a
second year you get 7 years out of the
guy how much more can you get out of a
running back before he starts to fall
off the cliff and by avoiding making the
huge financial commitment you don't find
yourself in the same posture the Rams
currently are with Todd Gurley a year
ago the Rams gave Todd Gurley that big
contract today I guarantee Kris they
would not do it again
they put themselves in a spot where they
owe him 34 and a half million fully
guaranteed that was as of March by next
March they have to make another decision
on guaranteeing another ten and a half
million dollars to Todd Gurley they have
a big decision looming if this guy's no
longer a workhorse why keep him and the
Cowboys want to avoid being in that spot
where they have multiple years tied up
in the decisions they're making about
Elliot they want to just pay him one
year at a time and if they ever get to
the point where he can't do it anymore
they move on to someone else they want
that flexibility I don't think they're
gonna get it from Elliot know that they
shouldn't an Ezekiel Elliott I mean if
you're listening and please don't do
that the hell with it just sit out
football then don't no one your one year
at a time crap not at that position not
with what everything you've done for the
football team
you led you'll let the NFL and carries
your first year in the NFL your third
year in the NFL
really would have let it his second year
in carries is well if he didn't have the
six game suspension he at least would
have been very close to the top if not
the leader the way he plays all of that
but hey going back to what Jerry Jones
said I mean first off he's got three
Super Bowl trophies and open up that's
right those three Super Bowl trophies
all had the rushing leader Emmitt Smith
of the NFL on those Super Bowl teams and
when you build the team to win games
through the run game with not only just
just bludgeoning people off the line of
scrimmage but controlling the time of
possession helping your defense out
there and then we have a pass game that
is not proven to this point you know yes
we saw flashes of memoria copper and dak
Prescott that looked really good last
year but as in a totality nobody's
scared of this Dallas Cowboy pass
offense yeah they got to show us more
with Kevin Moore so I think Zeke has
total power here get in shape get ready
Zeke and I think I'd want some point
you're gonna get all the money you want
he didn't have an injury like Todd
Gurley did either so we got to remember
that too yeah but that injury is one
snap away yeah that's part of the
concern and that's part of the the
approach that teams take with running
backs because you can always find
somebody else well they found somebody
else in Alfred Morris who has resigned
with the Cowboys he was there in 2017 he
was with the 49ers last year but Albert
Morris is not gonna scare details as the
way Elliott does right see how this one
plays out but the Cowboys at least for
now trying to push back we'll see if it
works we'll be back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports